lo que tenemos aquí es la gráfica de
igual a fx y estos números son el valor
de las áreas de estas regiones
sombreadas las regiones entre la curva y
el eje x lo que haremos en este vídeo
será resolver algunos ejercicios en
donde evaluaremos integrales definidas
usando la información y aplicaremos
nuestro conocimiento acerca de las
propiedades de las integrales definidas
así que empecemos con un ejemplo digamos
que queremos evaluar la integral
definida de menos 4 a menos 2 de fx de x
más la integral definida que va de menos
20 de fx de x
pausa el vídeo y observa si puedes
evaluar esta expresión completa bueno
esta primera parte de la expresión la
integral definida de menos 42 de fx de x
es decir vamos de x igual a menos cuatro
hasta x igual a menos dos y esto se va a
evaluar a esta área entre la curva y el
eje x pero será el valor negativo de esa
área porque nuestra curva está por
debajo del eje x podríamos estimar la
dada la información que nos dan pero no
tenemos el valor exacto de esta integral
sin embargo también tenemos que
encontrar esta segunda expresión esta
vez vamos de x igual a menos 2 hasta x
igual a 0 de fx de x y esto nos da esta
área
ahora si observamos la suma de estas dos
integrales definidas y observa el límite
superior de esta primera integral es el
mismo que el límite inferior de esta
segunda integral entonces lo que en
realidad estamos
y es que esto es lo mismo que la
integral definida que va desde x igual a
menos 4 todo esto hasta x igual a 0 de
fx de x
de hecho esta es una de nuestras
propiedades la integral si nuestro
límite superior de nuestra primera
integral es igual al límite inferior de
la segunda integral y como estamos
integrando la misma función entonces
podemos unir estas dos integrales de
esta forma y esto nos dará el área
entera pero como estamos debajo del eje
x y por arriba de nuestra curva entonces
será el negativo de esta área por lo
tanto ya puedo decir que esta integral
será igual a menos 7 muy bien hagamos
otro ejemplo imagina que alguien te
preguntan más por la calle y te dicen
hey rápido si tenemos esta gráfica
entonces cuál es el valor de esta
expresión el valor de la integral
definida de 0 a 4 de fx de x más la
integral definida de 4 a 6 de fx de x
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta
bueno una vez más en esta primera
expresión vamos de 0 a 4 por lo tanto
tendremos esta área que tiene un valor
de 5 y luego tenemos que restarle esta
área porque esta área está por debajo
del eje xy por encima de nuestra curva
aunque no sabemos con exactitud cuál es
su valor
para nuestra suerte necesitamos sumar
todo esto que te he mostrado con esta
segunda expresión aquí vamos de 4 a 6
así que será esta área que tengo aquí
una vez más cuando lo ves así puedes ver
que esta expresión es equivalente a ser
la integral definida de todo desde 0
hasta 6 df de x de x y una vez más
incluso sin ver la gráfica podemos saber
esto ya que tenemos la integral definida
de fx de x y nuestro límite superior de
la primera integral es el mismo que el
límite inferior de la segunda integral
una vez más podemos unir las integrales
y cuánto será esto bueno tenemos esta
área de aquí que tiene el valor de 5 y
después tenemos esta otra área de aquí
que tiene el valor de 6 pero esta
segunda área está por debajo del eje x y
por encima de nuestra curva es decir
cuando evaluamos esta integral definida
el valor que obtenemos es de menos 6 por
lo tanto esto será 5 + menos 6 lo cual
es menos 1 y hemos terminado nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo